Why don't we go next to let's go to Miguel
from Lima, Peru, one of the places I was to
visit in 2020. But then, Miguel, the pandemic
hit and I have not been able to do it yet.
It's too bad we would have liked you to be here.
I would have liked to have been there. Yes, I can.
So my question is about vaccinations, in
particular being from a country where only about
one percent of the population has been able to get
vaccinated. The issue being that we're not able
to get vaccines into the country as efficiently as
other countries have been. I know that some people
who have the economic capability to do to do it
are going to places like the US in order to get
vaccinated. Yes. And in some in some parts of
the US that's legal. I think in Texas it is.
And a lot of people personally who have been
there. And I wanted to know your opinion on the
morality behind people who aren't citizens of the
US going to the US specifically to get vaccinated?
Well, listen, the morality, it's less a question
of the morality of doing it. It's more of
is it allowed and or are they lying?
I mean, there was a bunch of time
where wealthy Argentineans were flying from Buenos
Aires to Miami and getting vaccinated in Miami and
doing shopping and then going back to Argentina.
And eventually when Florida found out about it,
they said they were stopping it, that you had to
show proof of residency in Florida. They said it.
But from what I understand, they're not really
checking. So you can just lie. So for me,
the morality is more about are you doing
something dishonest rather than if if that
if the rules are if if it's 65 plus, it doesn't
matter where you live, you could live in any
state, in any country as long as you're 65 plus
you're not really doing anything wrong. If you can
afford to go to that state and to get the vaccine,
it's really more of an administrative question.
I think the spirit of the doses that the Biden
administration has obtained are for Americans,
and that's economic nationalism. Countries are
mostly looking out for themselves right now.
And I understand why. And it's creating
a huge imbalance where there are poor
countries that that have very few vaccines
and may have none for a long period of time.
I don't know exactly how to solve that.
But the morality of an individual,
if the state is allowing it, the individual
is not really doing anything wrong.
Right. That makes sense. It's kind
of the way I'm seeing it, you know,
if I have the opportunity to go and get
vaccinated myself, or in particular,
my parents were older. Yeah, I would want them to
do that also. I mean, it's definitely an issue of
when we will be able to get vaccinated here in
Peru. And honestly, as someone who lives here,
it's it's mostly a question of when the US and
Europe will have reached a herd immunity. Everyone
who wants to get vaccinated has gotten vaccinated.
Well, understandably, those could be two different
things, too. You may have a situation in the U.S.
where everyone who wants it has gotten it and we
are not at herd immunity. That could happen.
That's a good point. At which point I would
hope that the US or Europe would just
sell the vaccines to countries like Peru
and then I could get vaccinated, you know.
Yeah, I think the US is planning to give them,
not just sell them. I think the US plans to give
them to other countries. Yep, there you go. So,
yes, all right, well, we're going to follow it and
hopefully, hopefully more vaccines and more places
soon, you know. Thank you, David. All right,
thank you. A beautiful phone call from Lima, Peru